carrasco's pitched well in the
postseason in the past but he's looking
for his first postseason victory tonight
to try to stave off elimination at home
gets him on another great pitch and a
strikeout ends the first back-to-back
punch-outs in a 1-2-3 beginning to the
night masahiro tanaka on the mound for
the yankees tonight he's been terrific
in the postseason in his career
a winner in five of his eight
post-season starts with a career fall
the array of 1.76
here's jose ramirez
had an rbi double last night
he swings and rockets it to right base
it down the line it'll go to the wall
for extra bases hernandez will score and
in standing with an rbi double is jose
ramirez
i mean they covered it and then there
was no rain and now they're covering it
by the way this is not it's not the
indians ground crew here major league
baseball makes these decisions we're
back after a delay a second delay
technically of roughly 30 minutes can
josh naylor
be one of those guys we hear about
every postseason
naylor stays hot that's going to roll
all the way to the wall
ramirez scores
reyes is being waved around
he'll score without a play and it's
three nothing indians
now roberto perez the right-handed
hitting catcher
perez with the base hit that ball just
ate up glaber torres
naylor's gonna score and it's four
nothing indians here is giancarlo
stanton
2-2 to stan is hit well out to right
field
naquin is back there he'll only watch
and big giancarlo has hit a homer in his
second straight game
stantonian home run
giancarlo
no sleepo stoppardo
so stanton homers yankees get on the
board
that might be a lot more important than
it looks sandy alamo he's gonna make the
move wow
frasco was rolling early on
but he runs into difficulty here and in
an elimination scenario
the leash gets a little bit shorter
factor in the rain delay he'll turn the
ball over to the hard throwing 25 year
old right hander james karen check base
is loaded no one out the batter is gio
or shella cleveland has a 4-1 lead we're
in the top of the fourth full count
pitch to herschela a swing and a drive
to left field geo orcillas hit a grand
slam
shella the most happy fella he grand
slams deep in the left center field
seats and the yankees take a 5-4 lead oh
and there was no question about that and
he hit that and i've nev you never seen
dj lemay who get really excited he was
banging on
on that railing
a misplayed ball on center field
back-to-back walks
a 3-2 fastball
bombs away
so the yankees have second and third and
no one out
another fast ball
just missed that one one that sit out to
right it's gonna be good enough to tag
and score hicks
boyd also advances and it's six to four
yankees he does depart with traffic
and he leaves the inherited runners to
chad green here in the fifth
his last 13 hits going back to the
regular season have all gone for extra
bases the 01 pitch swung on line drive
down the right field line fair ball this
should tie it on his way to
third is hernandez following lindor
lindor has scored here comes hernandez
the throw is high he slides and he's
safe
lead off walking the yankee half of the
sixth and now gary sanchez bigger bat
here for gary sanchez who's been under
the spotlight of new york city a big
gary
a drive out to right field it's carrying
naquin all the way to the wall he leaps
and it's gone
[Applause]
gary sanchez has untied the 6-6 score
and the yankees go back out on top
i mean gary did not think it was a home
run thought he missed it you see his
reaction
and then you see it going back back and
just runs out of room
big big home run
and the go ahead run does have a chance
to swing the bat this inning
and it happens to be the hottest
cleveland hitter jordan luplow is going
to pinch run wait a minute he's got a
bat in his hand hottest
hitter in baseball
i do not like this call at all it's a
one and two count to jordan luplow who
represents the go-ahead run
breaking ball hit in the air out to
straight away center field that's
trouble and it's off the base of the
wall
santana scores
reyes scores and the indians have tied
it up the move works
and the indians have come back again all
of this after two outs and nobody on
base and the yankees are selecting their
closer
[Applause]
but i would give him the green light
absolutely all right let's see if they
do something here first pitch to
hernandez is sent into left field and
it's a base hit as it drops in
the shields being waved around no play
at the plate cleveland goes on top nine
to eight
on the ground sharply hit great play by
herschela to le mayhew for one and the
yankees turn the double play wow
the next 3-2 another breaking ball tough
play for hand
and he won't have a play
the yankees have loaded the bases
2-2 to sanchez is sent out to center
field that'll do the job to tie the
score
talkman able to come in from third
and it's nine to nine
so the yankees hoping to get a base hit
out of
dj to give them the lead
and here is the o2 breaking ball is
grounded up the middle base hit
centerfield ashella coming home he will
score
it's a 02 basis by lemayo to centerfield
and the yankees take a 10-9 lead and now
her oldest chapman is a strike away from
sending the yanks to the division series
a swing and a miss it escapes evades
sanchez and mercado's going to get on
board
[Applause]
2-2 on the appeal he swung the bat and
the new york yankees have swept the
indians they've punched their ticket to
the division series